manifestations également à marseille où
enseignants et directeurs
d'établissements sont mobilisés pour
expliquer leur épuisement face au
protocole sanitaire à difficile à mettre
en place
balle au quotidien et les conditions de
travail effectivement c'est le fait qu'
on est des protocoles particulièrement
difficile à appliquer qui nécessite de
l'adaptation en permanence surtout quand
on a été en hausse en ciel après quand
on a été en abris dation maintenant
andrew ce retour avec des élèves qui ont
repris et et des profs qui ont repris
qui ont été largement contaminé pendant
les vacances et il faut gérer
l'absentéisme donc ça va être
fait recours par exemple avec la moitié
des places on se retrouve avec des
protocoles inapplicable toujours annoncé
à la presse de la veille pour le
lendemain et des textes institutionnels
qui ne suivent pas les dernières
annonces du premier ministre lundi soir
ont été traduites en textes
règlementaires hier soir donc ça suffit
maintenant
c'est un exemple de mépris avec lequel
on est traités les petites phrases et c
est donc il ya énormément de colère sur
un métier qu'on ne peut plus exercer
correctement et d'épuisement
professionnel une semaine après la
rentrée il faut appeler les paroles
auraient expliqué sans cesse les
changements
remettre en place avec nos équipes se
réadapter et c'est très très chronophage
un niveau c'est pour ça que j'ai mis sur
ma pancarte mais le terreau est restée
puiser parce que on tient on tient mais
on sent qu'on s'aime plus je sais
comment décorer que ce soit mes
collègues qui sont par ailleurs
enseignant des plus en plus j'ai jamais
entendu des gens dire qu'il voulait
autant dire qu'il voulait démissionner
qui voulaient arrêter qui craque